I think that it's time now to
incorporate Fisher random and in in the
rating system a universal rating system
has been designed to eventually count
every game to take taken account every
game that played on the planet I think
one day will be brother than position to
even to look for four games played
online providing people who were playing
these games will be able to prove the
strengths in life competition it's still
you know in distant future but that's
one of the ideas and I think it's it's
it's not a fair to tweet Fisher random
differently yes the it's a little bit
more chaotic I agree
but at the end of the day what the same
pieces the same rules the same board and
following this the suggestion of
astonishes with ratio just to create a
separate iterating for official random
could put us in a very odd situation
where you have classical rapid blitz
Fisher random why not to have them
united yeah try to actually find out the
the right balance so yes naturally you
probably you should downgrade Fisher
Fisher random compared to our to the
classical chess again because of this
elemental chaos in the opening position
following the the results of calcium
Kaka more match it's it's almost it was
almost the same as as as as if they play
the rapid and blitz so that's why I
don't see that this need is a huge gap
and many number of decisive games will
increase but I think it's very important
that will make sure that Fisher random
will be treated with the same respect
professionally as classical chess by the
way let's emphasize classical chairs is
position 518 it could hit in in chess
man 60